you were watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video over
the past year many times I've gotten a
request to create a video production on
the topic of tartar at first I didn't
really see why there was such a demand
but as I learned more about the company
it became clear that there was something
very unique you I have to admit before I
completed the research I really didn't
know much about tartar
besides the fact that they made cars
that were nowhere to be found in
Australia the US and Europe in fact the
only place I'd seen them was in India
during my travels today tartar now owns
companies such as Jaguar and Land Rover
but this is really the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to the breadth of
their industry activities so how did
Tata become the multinational giant that
it is today
and just how big is it in this video
we'll find out for those of you that are
from Western nations and are probably
unaware of this company this video may
widen your perspectives a little let's
begin as far as modern-day companies go
Tata is a very old company older than
the automobile powered flight and
household electricity the company was
founded way back in 1868 by Jamsetji
Nasser Ong Tata in retrospect after
Tatas success some have held Jai Tata as
one of the founders of modern India born
in 1839 Jai Tatas first professional
role was working in his father's banking
firm outside of Mumbai India
coincidentally where I was born there
was some key events in Jai Tatas life
that would shape the history of India
and eventually help shape the global
business landscape it would be travel
that opened his eyes Jai Tata travelled
to England America and Europe for
business and through his opportunistic
mind he saw that Indian companies could
make a large impact in the textile
industry which was dominated by the
British at the time in 1868 after
learning from his time working in his
father's banking firm a 29 year old Tata
bought an old oil mill and
murder into a cotton mill this seemingly
insignificant event was the very
beginning of the multinational giant J
Tata always had the inclination to care
greatly for the people of India and had
an interest in giving back
this is outlined by J Tatars for dream
gold during his life Tata strive for
four simple goals within his heart they
were to create an island steel company a
world-class education institution a
hotel and a hydroelectric plant it would
only be the hotel that was to become a
reality during Tatas life it was
completed one year before J Tatas death
in 1903 in 1907 Tata Sun door AB would
push to realize his dad's dream of Tata
Steel Asia's first and India's largest
steel company in 1911 the third dream
was completed in the form of the Indian
Institute of Science the preeminent
Indian institution for research and
education in science and engineering the
final piece of jade Tatas original dream
was realized in 1915 when Dora set up
Tata hydroelectric power supply company
now currently India's largest private
electric company so to do so many things
in so little time
may seem like immense innovation for the
early 20th century but there's a bigger
picture to this Tata as a company was
thinking differently even when compared
to global practice at the time to give
you an idea of how forward-thinking
title was for the time they started the
eight-hour workday in 1912 and were one
of the first companies in the world to
implement the now standard practice in
1917 the company introduced medical
benefits for employees a very advanced
business concept for the time since Jay
tatars founding of the company in 1868
the rains have been handed down to
multiple generations the company's DNA
would ensure success in the future
today Tata operates 100 companies in
more than 100 countries and exports to
150 countries so that's all nice but how
big is tighter exactly and what do they
do
well in 2014 the company made one
hundred three point two seven billion
dollars in revenue in which 67 percent
came from business outside of India the
Tartar companies employ more than five
hundred and eighty one thousand people
worldwide
that's more than Samsung Group by the
way Tata is ranked 34th among the top
500 most valuable global brands
according to brand finances global 500
2014 report so that gives you an idea of
financial size but what do they do
let's take a closer look at some of
Tatas companies we've got Tata Steel
Tata Motors consultancy services
chemicals global beverages tele services
communications and Indian hotels Tata
ceramics power
Tata Starbucks Tata industry Tata Sky
landmark bookstores and the list goes on
and just to top it off Tata actually
owns the South Korean car manufacturer
Daewoo but that isn't all Tata has
actually formed a habit of buying up
British companies it's rather ironic if
you know the 19th and 20th century
relations between India and Britain in
2000 they bought up the British company
Tetley tea for 407 million dollars and
then next there was Jaguar and Land
Rover in 2008 after the GFC for 2.3
billion dollars it's quite an
interesting story in 1999 resin Tata and
his team were humiliated when they went
to sell Tatas motor division to Ford due
to a poor response after a launch of a
hatchback which happened to be Todd's
first passenger car
the American Ford officials showed
interest and taking over the company but
did say in a harsh manner they told Tata
you did not know anything why did you
start a passenger car division at all
they said they'll do Tata a favor by
buying the car division but as it turns
out the deal didn't end up going through
between tarter and Ford at the time for
don't Jaguar and Land Rover and couldn't
really work out how to get the cars to
sell by 2008 things had gotten so bad
that Ford had to sell Jaguar and Land
Rover to the very company they had said
a few years earlier were useless today
Tata has turned Jaguar and Land Rover
around and sales are doing well in the
US ports from Jaguar Land Rover a quick
mention on the headline figures that we
saw coming out from Tata Motors
yesterday net profits have increased to
771 million dollars net sales on the
other hand have jumped 38% to about
63,000 or dark crore rupees now sales at
Jaguar Land Rover have jumped 19% driven
largely because of the demand that we
have seen coming in wood from the f-type
as well as the XJ okay so far in terms
of size
Tata may sound like a few other
multinational conglomerates but the
surprising difference here is that Tata
is actually very successful in many of
their fields for instance Tata
Communications is the world's largest
wholesale voice carrier and Tartar
Motors is among the top five commercial
vehicle manufacturers in the world their
steel division is among the top ten best
steel makers the communication services
division is among the top 10 global IT
service companies the global beverages
division is the second largest tea
company in the world and their chemical
division is the world's second largest
manufacturer soda ash which is used for
the manufacturing of glass another
aspect which makes Tartar different and
one of the reasons why I've grown to
appreciate them at least as a company is
their nature tarzo carries on its
founders caring attitude and as a result
they have a sort of self-imposed moral
obligation what do I mean by this the
company has actually made it a habit to
return some of its wealth to society
mainly through providing investments
back into the local economy this is not
only true within India but in many
countries around the globe
tarter is also very active in
philanthropy through its trusts the
company gives back in areas of medical
research technology science education
social welfare and health care one
example is the Titus watch a compact
in-home purification device that cost
less than 21 US dollars the idea of the
Titus watch came to being from the 2004
tsunami which left thousands of people
without clean drinking water
the device has filters that last about
one year for a family of five the
advantage of this device is that it does
not require any electricity and is very
low cost due to activities like this
in 2009 the title group was ranked
number 11 in the world's top 100
reputable companies by Forbes magazine
so there you have it a true
multinational conglomerate with a bit of
difference all in all it's amazing that
just one man could leave a legacy that
has lasted over a century let's finish
off with a quote from J Tata himself in
a free enterprise the community is not
just another stakeholder in the business
but in fact the very existence of it
what he said rings as true today as it
did over 100 years ago companies really
need to listen to their communities and
users and one last cool fact J Tata has
even founded a city in India that now
has over 1.3 million people I hope you
enjoyed that video about the history and
size of Tata if you did please give this
video a thumbs up I really appreciate it
feel free to leave a comment and
subscribe if you're new if you want to
know more about the history science and
interesting facts about other companies
hang around for the next 10 seconds and
follow the prompts in your screen this
has been - gogo you've been watching
cold fusion and I'll see you again soon
for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion it's me thinking